sql has many built-in functions for
performing calculations on data
but sometimes your systems might need to
handle data such as string or date
values in a unique way
user-defined functions are an efficient
way to have these custom calculations
at your fingertips when analyzing data
on today's episode of bigquery spotlight
we're talking about how to create store
and share user-defined functions in
bigquery
so stick around
so what is a user-defined function or
udf
a udf lets you create a reusable
function which you define
with either another sql expression or
with javascript
these functions accept input perform
actions and then return a value as a
result
once you've created a udf you can
reference it in queries or when creating
logical views
just as you would with built-in
functions let's see an example use case
imagine an application that captures
data from various sources
and requires any text fields to be
cleansed before they can be used for
analytical purposes
we can write one udf we'll call it
cleanse string
to tackle this data cleansing problem
the sql expression that defines the udf
does
three things it trims white spaces
converts text to lowercase and removes
symbols
after creating and defining the udf in
the next part of the query statement
we can test three different strings of
text through our new function
if we run the entire query we will see
the before and after results for each
string of text
once we are happy with the function's
performance we could add it to the query
statements that analyze data from our
application
this example includes what we call a
temporary udf
meaning it is created and used within
one single query statement
however bigquery also supports
persistent udfs which are defined and
stored within a specific project and
data set
but can be reused across multiple
queries and projects
let's head into the console and see how
to create use and share a persistent udf
you can follow along in your own
bigquery sandbox
if you don't have one yet set one up
following the video link below
it's good to note that in the sandbox
your persistent udfs will remain
indefinitely
so they aren't limited to the same
60-day storage limit that tables have
within the sandbox
start in the query editor here you'll
define your udf using sql following a
specific syntax
create or replace function indicates
that you would like to create
a persistent udf this is followed by
your project id and data set name
where you want the udf to live next is
the name for the function itself
in this case cleanse underscore string
following
in parentheses is a comma separated list
of all input parameters with their data
types that your udf requires
for cleanse string you have just one
input which is a string of text
on the next line the return clause
specifies the data type that the
function will return
now it's time to provide a sql
expression that defines how to process
the input
this expression uses the sql function's
trim to trim white space
and lower to convert the text to lower
case
then it uses a regular expression to
remove any symbols
now you're ready to click run to create
the persistent udf
you will see it populate under your data
set in the left hand nav selecting the
udf allows you to view
edit or delete it but first let's use it
we'll bring up the same query that we
showed earlier in the video but this
time we can reference the persistent udf
without needing to provide its
definition within the same query
statement
going forward you can use this udf just
like you would any other sql function
directly within your query statements
you will need to reference it with its
full name including the project and data
set in which it resides
in fact any user with the adequate
permission to the data set containing
the udf
such as the bigquery data viewer role
can also reference it in their queries
by sharing data sets you have the
potential to create an org-wide library
of udfs
which in turn can ensure business logic
is applied consistently and efficiently
across your organization
now that you know how to create and use
udfs in bigquery
it's time to start writing some of your
own if you're looking for inspiration
or perhaps to just not reinvent the
wheel check out the resources link below
they include several udf examples
including many written in javascript
thanks for joining us today for bigquery
spotlight watch out for the next episode
and remember
stay curious
[Music]
you